right on time at 110
walker to harrison basketball in there
and just like yesterday
a line drive to right field wait are we
showing highlights or is this live
first pitch of the game give them the
entire
third baseline with jd playing in the
shortstop position
he had two balls hard to left field
yesterday right down the line
he was about to go on a 3-2 pitch was
leaning the wrong way
and taiwan walker who came close earlier
gets him leaning the wrong way for the
first out of the game
well i think josh harrison knows that
that is a
big boo boo you full count but he walked
six in his last star and he's already
walked one today
turner reaches for one and lines it to
right the performer gets over
grab it hernandez will hold it second
and that's the second out
turner might have swing with ball four
[Applause]
and bell lines one
last start was on the 20th against the
cardinals he was real good
six shutouts gave up just four hits
struck out
five to the right side
bell will scoop it up and going himself
in there and he popped him up on three
and one and lindor is very upset at
himself
[Applause]
two outs so two out now jd davis who has
three career home runs against patrick
corbin
breaking ball hit in the ear to center
field back goes wall class to the
warning trash back
jd davis strikes again against patrick
corbin
a two-run homer to put the mets in front
early
second home run of the year for jd and
his fourth career
shot in 27 at bats against patrick
corbin
one out walk comes back to hunt it was
pete alonso
and that one right to castro on the
backhand side
here's the one-two fouled into the mid
of mccann who holds on strike three
a 94 mile an hour fastball and starlin
castro down on strikes
he's running and they got him picked off
bell high throw
and trey turner pulls it down
josh bell comes out meets the throw
textbook then he kind of gooses it
to trey but trey being the athlete he is
like a jump
and tag all at once that was pretty
and robles drives one toward the gap in
right center field and that's going to
go all the way to the wall
roblox can fly he's the second he's
going to make the turn and try for three
the relay throw by vr to third and he
is out perfect
relay by jonathan vr and robles makes
the first out of the inning at third
base
mets have made some great relays they
did in chicago and now they do
in this game that's need a clutch hit
here from turner with two on and two
outs
fly ball out to right center hit pretty
well conforto back though has room on
the warning track
and makes the catch to retire the side
walker escapes
another difficult inning like on the
horizon and you get
closer and just opens up for you
and a swing and a miss and walker uses
the high fastball to blow away schwarber
for his second strikeout second and
third nobody out mets with a two-nothing
lead in the fourth
james mccann grounded out to short his
first time up
and mccann grounds one down through the
hole for a base hit
that'll bring in davis conforto moves up
a bag
james mccann finds a hole three straight
hits for the mets producer run and it's
three nothing new york
they are singled left field first time
and he'll lift this one to left
schwarber one way to go
and he's gonna grab it runner and third
know where to go what a good play by
kyle
schwarber
[Music]
okay this is all me i got it not a
problem
pops up quick and forto shuffled down
the line didn't tag up so a big outs
and a nice recovery so to speak by kyle
schwarber
i think he thought his shortstop was
going to take that and then he knew it
was all him and he made a nice play
and he'll get him pace is occupied no
need to tag the runner or make a throw
two down
so now the merry-go-round will be in
motion conforto at third mccann at
second al moore at first we'll all be
running
and he's going to get the call on the
fastball down and away
patrick corbin as big a strikeout
as you can get now he can switch gears
and
and get away with it for a while and
lindor with a
gorgeous catch for the first out
beautiful play
making like gumby reach into the
backhand side
well one thing's for certain that we've
seen from lindor he's
struggling with the bat he doesn't let
it affect
his defense beautiful play and gomes
hang with him
now pete alonso strolls to the plate to
begin the bottom of the fifth inning and
juano to alonso crushed deep left center
robles
back there she goes a long way
oh wow pete alonso crushes one
and the mets laid it four nothing fifth
home run of the year for alonso and that
was crushed i could tell off the bat
that
pete just smacked it and the ball just
kept rising as it headed out of the park
that ball was absolutely torched 109
off the bat
into left schwarber
little momentum lindor tagging
coming home and the call is out
nice safe sir oh he's out oh he never
never touched he's out yeah he's gonna
be out
never touched the plate he's out
but what a throw what a tag so a huge at
bat right here for
uh walker to get out of this jam so it's
a four nothing ball game
got a guy with some pop that can make it
a 4-3 ball game in a hurry
fly ball center field chasing almora
back way back to the warning
track and he made the catch albert
elmora
he ran a country mile
first start of the year for almora and
he saves two runs with a gem
tremendous catch by albert elmora jr
and that retires the side now ryan
zimmerman is batting for trey turner he
was hit by the pitch in the the
the forearm elbow area last time up two
and two to zimmerman
and he lays off the slider and castro
didn't get the call
from doug eddings and it's three and two
three and two with josh bell on deck
got him lucky wasn't going to give him
two in a row like that
well that one at the bottom of the
strike zone gets zimmerman for the
second half
o2 coming struck him out
three change-ups in a row and castro
strikes out bill to strand two in
scoring position
on the ground alonso with the diving
stop diaz covers
and the ball game is over on a terrific
defensive day for the match speed lonzo
turns in the final gem